[Music]
what you doing today well since we've
got the drywall all up I'm gonna do a
little bit of spackling here and that's
not cocaine that's our mix baby put that
on the hall put a nice coat on the joint
here enough nice even spread first coat
doesn't have to be perfect there will be
two coats after that
[Music]
he is to get all the excess this gets
done throughout the whole corners in the
place pretty much three coats then we'll
come back and show you about the sanding
and priming
hey it's good to shoot out yeah you know
you were coming today so I wanted to
sanding process right now I've sanded
all the walls in the back this whole
sidewall got my mask on double
protection Corona and us so as far as
the San Diego SEC just you can see it's
the best kind of business you got to
feather out all this smooth that gets
done April comes some PVA primer on that
and then you know we'll show you that in
the next episode I think I will take my
heart pills oh yes and I tried getting a
mask on them but it wouldn't fit but you
see the size of this guy's head
[Music]